a-l-e-x-a-n-d-e-r-c-u-e-v-a-s
i'm the public information officer with
the north las vegas police department
so before we begin today's uh press
briefing i will introduce you to our
speakers
and as for that in order of appearance
it is going to be
north las vegas mayor john lee that is
spelled
j-o-h-n-l-e-e he's the mayor of the city
of north las vegas next will be council
woman pamela goins-brown
that is spelled p-a-m-e-l-a-g-o-y-n-e-s
hyphen
b-r-o-w-n
and then it will be acting police chief
jacqueline gravatt that is spelled
j-a-c-q-u-e-l-i-n-e
g-r-a-v-a-t-t
[Music]
and with that
here is merely
thank you we had an unprecedented loss
of life that happened yesterday in our
community
it was a tragedy
it was beyond sad
each of these people was a relative
a husband a wife a child a neighbor a
member of our community a very valuable
member of our community
we need to realize today that there's a
lot of grieving taking place in north
las vegas our hearts are full for these
families
we really
care when something happens in a
community that just pulls the heart
right out of it
we hope and pray that this family will
understand that this grieving process
will take them and us in the city of
north las vegas a long time
and we appreciate them understanding
that the city of north las vegas values
them and their families
thank you very much
good evening
on behalf of the city council
and our community
i wanted to extend my deepest control
condole condolences to the families of
all the victims
all of the north las vegas we mourn with
this family
we mourn with you today
this is an unfathomable tragedy
that has forever altered the lives of so
many people
our hearts and prayers are with those
who are experiencing this unimaginable
pain
their loss is our entire community's
loss
i also want to recognize our tremendous
north las vegas first responders
the care and respect that they showed
everyone involved their dedication and
compassion
the work they do is not easy
and scenes like yesterday will forever
be in their hearts
and their minds
we will hold everyone impacted by this
tragedy
in our hearts
good afternoon everyone
i wanted to update you on the facts that
we know him at this time in reference to
the multiple vehicle traffic accident
yesterday
yesterday at 3 15 we were contacted
about a multi-vehicle traffic accident
in the area of cheyenne and commerce
there were six vehicles involved and 15
individuals
there were imma go through the vehicles
in their descriptions there was a dodge
challenger who had two occupants both
who succumbed to their injuries
there was a toyota sienna van that had
seven occupants
all succumbed to their injuries
we had a ford fusion
with one adult occupant
who is currently in serious condition at
umc medical center
a chevy malibu
with one occupant
that was injured and released
a mercedes suv with two adult occupants
injured and released
and there was a ford fusion
i think i went over the fusion with the
serious
condition at umc
in this accident we do know that the
dodge challenger was traveling
northbound on commerce at a high rate of
speed it was the only vehicle traveling
northbound at this time
witnesses on scene said that the
challenger did
not stop at the red light
it went through the intersection
first striking two vehicles that were
traveling eastbound and due to that
collision three additional vehicles were
struck that were going westbound
speed was a factor
in this accident
and that is the only contributing factor
that we know of at this time
the sole vehicle heading northbound on
cheyenne
again was occupied by two individuals
due to the magnitude of this injury the
ntsb will be assisting us with this
investigation we are currently
anticipating them meeting with our
traffic division tomorrow
the heartfelt condolences to the
families and everyone affected by this
horrific incident it affects us as a
community as a valley and as a nation as
a whole
the red cross has been in contact with
our agency because they want to reach
out to those families and we are
currently diligently working on
providing those families information to
the red cross
again the north las vegas police
department the city of north las vegas
and the las vegas valley are all at a
loss
we are sending our condolences and any
support for these families that can be
expressed we encourage you to do so
thank you
last these are all very preliminary
we are anticipating getting results from
downloads of vehicles speed work up
and things of that nature the reports
from the coroner's office once we get
that information we'll be able to update
you again and provide you more specifics
but again this is extremely preliminary
we just wanted to make sure we had all
the facts as we know them right now out
to you as soon as we could thank you
i think the hardest part of this and it
may have been
just the unintentional
um
not addressing because it's extremely
tragic
the toyota sienna van had seven
occupants four juveniles and three
adults and all three all seven succumbed
to their injuries
in the accident making a total of nine
nine people that perish during this
incident
thank you
all right
i'd like to thank everyone for joining
us here as for all uh
press media outlets
you will be receiving a press release
print
for later that will have access to
photos of vehicles on scene
at this time as chief has stated this
information is very preliminary it only
happened about 24 hours ago
things have the possibility of changing
and with that there are going to be no
questions answered today okay thank you
so much and have a good day